welcome back to the 58th ever episode of
the iced coffee hour podcast my name is
george
and so far the podcast has made 69
435 dollars he says 69.
that's incredible that is incorrect i
think that was the best one we've ever
seen on the podcast are you serious
really
i am not joking at all i felt it yeah
yeah i'm serious
and by the way thank you we are so close
to 69 420.
no are we really 69 435 yeah wow
well done congratulations yeah thank you
so much for coming on george
always thanks for having me this has
been really exciting because i kid you
not i have watched your channel
for honestly since you were probably
10 000 ish subscribers and right now
your channel is approaching 900
000 subscribers we talk about aquarium
fish
reef keeping saltwater aquarium
husbandry
and you travel the world just showcasing
some of the most exotic
expensive fish and coral out there how
did you start
doing this because i found your channel
in a college dorm room
and you had like a little nano tank with
a clown fish and an anemone in there
right
yeah so this hobby started for me in
actually middle school i believe
so i was 10 years old and i just really
wanted a fish tank and my mom
took me to a fish store and she's like
you know these fish are
all fresh water but i think you should
do salt water and that was really
interesting because most people don't
even know the difference between
freshwater saltwater aquariums
you know they just go to their local
petco or something and pick something up
so we went to a saltwater fish store i
got my first
12 gallon uh reef tank which is salt
water which means you get to keep things
like corals
much more like exotic fish and different
invertebrates and
so then basically what happened was i
got really addicted to
like keeping uh the coral you know
that was sort of what hooked me into the
hobby because i just found it so
fascinating the way coral grows
if you can grow it you can cut it and
then you can sell it
to other hobbyists you can actually make
a good amount of money doing it as you
saw from
as you've seen now being in the hobby
yourself yeah how much quartz go for
so that like really piqued my
entrepreneur
minded you know young george and that's
kind of what got the ball rolling for me
to just sort of like dive really deep
into the
world of aquariums it's weird that a
parent would tell their child let's go
salt water
it's bizarre because it's like the most
yeah my mom is i mean
totally crazy for doing that you know
it's very it's a very expensive hobby
yeah
most parents you know they just want to
get their kid the quick and easy thing
yeah the goldfish yeah the betta fish my
mom was like
we're gonna get you like the baller like
best coolest thing you can possibly do
and it's crazy because if she hadn't
done that like i always wonder if she'd
if i got into fresh water
who knows maybe i would have just you
know phased out of it after a few months
or gotten bored
why was that was she is she like a total
fanatic for the saltwater aquarium maybe
she
has a lot of money how do i how do i get
rid of it as fast as possible
oh here's the saltwater crown let's
bring that out no my dad
definitely was i don't think he under
quite understood the hobby or what was
going on at the time
um yeah but my mom's just like amazing
for that reason like she always just
has always encouraged us to do to just
like go all out and go
to be the best at whatever we try to do
um and
i didn't learn this until like many
years later but my mom
actually kept saltwater aquariums with
her dad my grandpa growing up
yeah that was it so what's interesting
though is back when she was keeping them
they could only have saltwater fish like
the technology wasn't around to keep
coral alive
so it was actually kind of a new thing
for her too to like
walk back into a saltwater aquarium
store and be like wait you can keep
coral now
and so yeah i mean that was that's
really why
so what was your first tank my first
tank was um it was called the 12 gallon
nano cube and that's where my name coral
fish 12 g comes from 12.
okay yeah and um it's interesting with
aquariums
you'd think that the smaller they are
the easier they keep but it's actually
the opposite
so the smaller the reef aquarium the
harder it is to take care of because
the chemicals um you have less uh
room for error right because you only
have such a small water volume
it's like if you were to take a drop of
poison and like put it in there
there's no room for free like it's going
to kill everything versus if you were to
take a drop of poison and like throw it
in the ocean
you won't even notice got it so the
bigger the aquarium actually the easier
so
it was very challenging and i failed in
so many different ways like
i went through all the pests i went
through pretty much every problem you
can imagine
as a young kid too and then after about
two years of that
i find in killing a decent amount of
coral i figured out
how to keep coral alive and how to get
my tank just to look amazing
and then that's when i took to youtube
to teach other people how to not make
the same mistakes i made
what made you post youtube videos oh how
old were you dude this was
freshman years no this was middle school
even like i think
you're posting youtube videos in middle
school i was yeah i'm really doing this
along
yes i i started my channel in 2010
i remember i didn't know that wow yeah
but i think i
i think i posted probably my first video
in like 2011 or 2012.
and at first it was just videos of my
fish tank because i just wanted to see
what people thought of them and that's
sort of what youtube was back then it
was just like a place where you like put
stuff to see like what happened
um then i saw there were like other
people teaching about aquariums
and i looked up to them and then that
inspired me to like
you know start giving my advice and my
you know two cents on everything in the
hobby yeah
i remember when i was in middle school i
had an aquarium and you would think that
it's like this nerdy hobby
but anytime someone come over it was
like whoa look at the
look at the fish and everyone was
enamored by it everyone loved it
yeah it was um it was sort of
interesting for me because i also played
basketball growing up actually
into college even so i played college
basketball as well
and so my whole life this happened was
more in
high school where i realized i started
thinking like hey
maybe i should like give up this
aquarium thing because i was like the
you know starting point guard varsity
basketball team supposed to be like this
jock right then i had this like weird
side hobby of
keeping like super nerdy saltwater
aquariums and like no one knew about it
in high school
so you didn't share it with people no i
didn't were you embarrassed of it yeah i
mean like
you guys have to remember like youtube
back then was not cool it was
it just wasn't what it is today like
true you know now everybody wants to be
a youtuber like i think i remember
seeing the number one sought after job
by kids
youtuber but back then it was it was not
cool especially
not aquariums at least i didn't think so
and so i mean i told like
a few of my closest friend knew about it
but most people did not know
did you have a following at that time i
had maybe in high school so what
happened was
right around high school i think i had
like a couple thousand subscribers
um and i remember thinking like
you know the what if people see this
what's going to happen
uh you know i think it's the same thing
if you are people are going to start
making fun of me and stuff
and so i consider stopping it but then
what actually kept me in it
was i started receiving checks from
youtube i was receiving like a couple
hundred bucks a month
that's pretty good for a high schooler
that's really good for high schoolers
yeah and youtube videos yeah
yeah so i was like hey well if anyone
makes fun of me for this i'm just going
to tell them
uh to go kick rocks because i'm making
money from it yeah so i was gonna that
was gonna be like my way of justifying
it yeah
and then i also started like companies
started reaching out even back like that
early
and they were sending me free product
and that was epic for me as a young kid
because i
again aquarium's very expensive and so
like receiving free lights and
free equipment was really cool so um
yeah then what happened was i went off
to college
kind of a clean slate i committed to go
play basketball at
a very small school called lawrence
university in appleton wisconsin
which is about three hours north of
where i grew up in chicago
and uh i had i remember i had 10 000
subscribers my freshman year of college
and my best friends were actually
baseball players yeah
and it wasn't until the end of the year
that like the way my best friend uh
found out was
i had accidentally left one of my
business cards like it just was like
laying
out in the hallway or something like
embarrassing well
i don't know i was i didn't know what
was going to happen but
basically he texted me a photo of the
card and he's like
what is this and i was like oh man
everyone's about to know about this
within a week everyone at the college
knew that i was you know
and how was it was it as bad as you
thought no it was it wasn't actually a
lot of people thought it was really cool
um and even my best friends were like
dude this is epic like why didn't you
tell us about this like this is sick you
got 10 000 subscribers
like um so that felt good
but um and you know encouraged me to
keep doing it i also had
i brought my fish tanks or my fish tank
to college
uh my freshman year i only had one by my
senior year i had 15.
15 tanks in my dorm room yeah i had
almost 15
13 or 14 fish tanks in my dorm room and
i had like all the most exotic animals
so it was like you would walk into my
dorm room and it was a public
square yeah it's like a zoo you had like
sea horses clown fish
mantis shrimp like planted tank
um just like all sorts of exotic stuff
that's cool i was the same way i didn't
tell anyone about my youtube channel
at all it's a scary feeling yeah on
facebook i've never posted about the
youtube channel oh i've never told my
friends about my youtube channel they
found out yeah yeah
yeah over time they found out but i it
made me more worried knowing that like
my friends were watching
and i would feel like i'd hold myself
back because i knew like oh they're
watching me what do i what if i say
something
bad yeah i mean everyone says supportive
at least for me
i mean if you weren't into aquariums you
might just be like oh it's cool yeah
just kind of brush it off
so at that advantage yours is a little
bit more personal right so
yeah but when you were making these
videos
how many other people were making reef
aquarium videos were you one of the
first ones
but first i want to thank our sponsor
ladder i want to talk for a minute about
things that have fundamentally changed
the way we live
these are disruptors things like
smartphones streaming services
wider than white paint that actually
cools down buildings
electric vehicles and even youtube
another one i heard of recently is a
company called ladder who basically took
the life insurance industry flipped it
upside down
and check out the inefficiencies before
latter if you wanted to get life
insurance you'd have to drive across
town
sit through a sales pitch fill out a ton
of paperwork and then wait six to eight
weeks to find out if you've been
approved you'd also receive a zillion
phone calls from agents trying to bundle
your life insurance with other things
like car insurance
now with ladder you can get fast
affordable term life insurance without
leaving home
it's a hundred percent digital when you
apply for three million dollars or less
in coverage
no doctors no needles no paperwork so if
you're between the ages
of 20 to 60 need coverage and want to
team up with a company that's redeeming
life insurance
choose ladder i know that when i went
through the process of getting quotes
through ladder it was so
fast and easy and i didn't need to dig
out a bunch of old paperwork go to
ladderlife.com
iced coffee today to see if you're
instantly approved that's
l-a-d-d-e-r-life.com
iced coffee ladderlife.com iced coffee
thank you so much ladder for sponsoring
this episode and back to the podcast
i you know i think a lot of people in my
industry or at least in the youtube you
know aquarium youtube would definitely
i would consider myself one of those og
aquarium youtubers
um i wasn't the first to it by any means
but i was
in it very early on
and and yeah i mean eventually so every
year of college it
my channel grew it actually doubled so
freshman year 10 000 sophomore year 25
junior year 50 and then my senior year i
got to 100 actually ended up surpassing
100 but
um yeah and just basically what happened
was like i never
because i was playing college basketball
that was my focus
all throughout middle school high school
was like how do i play college
basketball
so i was very very driven and focused on
that
first and then the aquariums and youtube
was sort of like a side hobby
and it was just like some side income i
didn't really start taking it seriously
until
probably my junior senior year of
college
when you know a lot of companies started
noticing and they started flying me out
to aquarium conventions
uh to do marketing and um
and then it wasn't really until and i
always wanted to do youtube full-time
like i always thought like you you know
being a youtuber would be like
the coolest thing i i think i would have
even back then as a young kid considered
it my dream job
it's just i never thought that
it could be a full-time income like a
full-time job i think there's a big
misconception
with a lot of small youtube creators
where
they just don't they don't realize that
how close they are how
achievable it is to make youtube a
full-time job
you know they think like i remember
thinking oh those big youtubers like
you know the ones with over a million or
five million like somehow they can you
know they're making a lot of money from
it but i
i didn't realize at the time that other
creators with 50 or
even only a hundred thousand subscribers
even sometimes with like 10
25 000 subscribers can you know through
affiliates or through
brand deals or through just like
dominating their niche
earned a full-time living so it was
until my senior year when um
like another aquarium youtuber actually
messaged me
a uh and this was like yeah so like
this is like literally rewired my brain
yeah um
no no i can't but it was it was an
aquarium youtuber who
uh was making like i think he sent me a
because i
i had my first viral video my senior
year and then i started getting like a
lot of attention a lot of other creators
were like bigger creators were reaching
out and you know i was
starting to like meet them and talk to
them and stuff
he's like why aren't you doing this full
time i'm like what do you mean like i
can't
i don't i can't make enough money to do
this whole time i can't even go to my
parents until
i wouldn't even dare go to my parents
say like i could do this because
it just wouldn't be enough because at
that time i was making like
most of throughout most of college was
making about a thousand dollars a month
so i was like twelve thousand of the
year like i can't do that
yeah but then after my first final video
it clicked like my senior year my first
viral video which was don't
uh don't buy fly fish off the dark web
and that got five million views why why
shouldn't you buy fish off the dark web
i don't know you gotta watch graham
but you have to explain it because now
we have an entire audience that's gonna
click out of this video go watch that
and thank you for putting this title
card right here into the video
no we don't use time it's bad for the
algorithm oh is it actually yeah it is
because very few people ever click out
of a title card
think of it i mean if you're watching a
video it's true have you have you ever
when they say oh yeah middle of the
video peak suspense
click the title card go watch another
video it works against you because
that's a click against the out like
any any option that people don't follow
through
counts against you the algorithm all
right we're throwing the link in the
description everyone
go check it out in the description that
you could watch later yeah
yeah so the idea was the idea was um
you know how how can i and this is also
what was like a turning point
point for my channel was how do i get
more people interested in aquariums like
how do i get me the mainstream
interested in learning about aquariums
fish or you know
conservation with marine and different
marine animals which that ended up
that's you know a later part of what i
do
but um and i realize okay i really need
these viral ideas
where um so i thought okay what's the
scariest fish you could possibly unbox
like what's the scariest fish you guys
could probably the angler well
yeah you're a reef yeah yeah yeah jack
what about you what's the
scariest fish what would you not want to
be in the water with
a great white shark or a tiger shark
or besides sharks stingray yes i
wouldn't want it
jellyfish maybe amazon think about the
amazon prana oh
yeah yeah you wouldn't want to be in the
water with piranha there's this big
misconception piranhas because of movies
and
even sharks too um and i've made a lot
of videos about sharks
and and uh with the same logic that
you know the movies the media make
sharks piranhas a lot of these animals
out to be like
villains very scary when really like
piranhas are
so timid and shy they're very very like
but
they're like coyotes where like one is
timid and shy but then when you have a
pack of them if they just go
it's freezing blood in the water yeah
i've seen those they're hungry
yes but if you keep them in your
aquariums like they're more scared of
you than you are them i've seen some
where they put like a fish in a piranha
tank like a little like half-eaten fish
and they just
rip this thing apart it's it's knots yes
but if you put like a whole human hand
in the tank
they're very like they're more likely to
go hide because you're like a bigger
animal than there
unless they're in like a massive swarm
in the amazon but regardless that the
video was basically
unboxing piranhas and teaching people
how to take care of them in their
aquariums all about them the
misconceptions
um and they are like i mean they're not
not um
they are dangerous animals like you
wouldn't want to like you guys said be
in the amazon river swimming with
piranhas
but i've also heard from a lot of people
that they've walked like through
like piranha-infested waters like no
problem so
i mean it goes both ways but um
yeah after my first viral video and i
saw how many views i got
i saw how much i got paid for it how
much you get paid for it i think i got
like
uh at least that first month i got like
five six thousand dollars
okay which for a college student yeah
you're like five million views like
ready to go to the casino man
you're rich so um and i was like okay
this is what people want to watch this
is why people watch this
and this is how much you make when you
nail it right you hit it on the head you
go viral
and so and then since then i've just
been able to sort of recreate that viral
formula
and i've been able to just have lots of
viral videos since i graduated college
which was
two years ago and i've been able to turn
it into a full-time
you know living which i never thought i
could do what's your formula for a viral
video i'm curious from your perspective
because you've had some videos just go
nuts yeah i have and like for me it's
all about
um i think there is a golden rule to
going viral you know there's a
there's a lot of people who think i
think if you ask the average person
they'd say oh
viral you know i just you threw a video
of your dog up on facebook and it went
viral
like no i think there's a very like
there's a
there's a formula to viral i think
there's a golden rule
and the golden rule is that you need to
make people feel
an emotion you need to make people feel
like
happy scared anxious something something
to the point where they take that piece
of content
and then they share it because as humans
like it's built into our dna like
when you feel something really intense a
powerful emotion
like what do you want to do you want
others to feel that same way like when
you watch something funny
you want to share it so that you know
your friend or your
your husband or wife or whatever you
know feels that as well
so i think that's just like um i think
that's what viral is is when you can
really get someone's like emotions uh to
change
and you can kind of like impact the way
that they're they're feeling
you know because then they'll share it
and then um and so i think
it's a very powerful thing so for you
what does that look like because
i've but first i want to thank our
sponsor surfshark nowadays more than
ever we are spending so much time online
for me
i just love to watch youtube videos
check the price of whatever coin the
internet seems to be going on about and
see what papa elon is sharing on his
twitter and trust me the internet knows
a lot about us and that is exactly why
we should care about our online data
that's where surfshark comes in
surfshark is a vpn that encrypts your
data when you're browsing online so that
no one else can see your personal
information and since they keep
no logs not even surf shark can see what
you've been up to online
i also love using surfshark for
streaming let's say i wanted to watch
rick and morty on netflix well you see
in the united states it's actually not
available but if i use surfshark to
change my location to the united kingdom
i'm now able to watch rick and morty
wherever i go
this means you can also change your
location to other countries on your
favorite streaming sites and see a whole
new list of shows to choose from get
started today by clicking the link in
the description and use the code iced
coffee for 83
off and three extra months for free and
if you don't love it for
any reason there's a 30 day money back
guarantee again just click the link in
the description and use the code iced
coffee to get three months for free
thank you so much surfshark for
sponsoring this episode and back to the
podcast
my favorite video for me was a stingray
one it was just the stingray breeder in
singapore
in singapore yeah that didn't make me i
mean i was more curious explain
the plot of the video you want to
explain it or you want me to explain it
from a viewer's perspective yeah why
don't you explain you went to this
it looks like this guy's house and we
should throw by the way alex let's throw
some like b-roll over top
we went to this guy's house or you we
went too i said
if i was there i may as well have been
you filmed first person oh no no you
did you film first person it's so funny
you say that because i
very intentionally try to make my videos
feel like the viewer is there like
taking the tour with me yeah
i use different like angles and
different like lenses to
give the viewer that feeling like
they're walking around and looking at it
yeah that's cool but um
was there someone that i don't remember
i had my uh my cameraman asher who's
traveled with me to like
okay quite a few countries so anyway so
it looked like it was first person but
you were walking through
this dude who is so passionate about
stingrays
and what's cool about these stingrays is
that they were like five thousand
two to three thousand dollars on the low
end for like a little stingray all the
way up to like 20 25
30 000 for a stingray they had like
stingrays with different spots on them
and like white ones
black ones and cool patterns and one
looks like a question mark on it's
really cool stuff but every square inch
of this guy's spot
was a stingray like you're walking on
the floor over
stingrays the whole wall is a stingray
there's a stingray like
above you it was knots and every single
singer he must have had like
a million two million dollars for the
stingrays that he just breeds
and it was one of these things it's like
every moment he says something that's
like what this is
crazy a million to two million dollars
worth of stingrays
yeah is the value in an expensive
stingray because like you can sell it
and people can enjoy it or because you
can breed it like a horse and you can
like
it's both it's both it's both yeah like
um
but it's more i mean the econom on the
economic side it's definitely because
you can breed it
and once you have it you know you can
yeah it's like a horse in that sense
yeah
but um yeah i mean it it's crazy
that's just like there's so many
different facets to aquariums there's so
many different animals
and um it's not entirely like i've sort
of gotten used to it now like where
there's a there's a stingray guy there's
a flower horn guy which is a different
type of fish there's clownfish guys like
and they transform their entire homes to
be these like
insane breeding facilities um and that
that's
the cool thing about um you know when
you kind of travel overseas
is a lot of those people like that's
their livelihood right
and so they are just like doing it out
of their homes and like converting
i was once when i was in thailand uh a
guy converted an
entire residential apartment building
into like a flower horn
fish it's a type of fish uh like
breeding like place and you literally
five floors and every floor i just was
like
footage of that i do i have a whole
video on it alex how much
yeah yeah how much is this guy making
because the stingray guy by the way
you go up to this unassuming building
like you would have no idea
the gate opens up there's a brand new
bmw i8 just sitting there
and this dude pulls out shows you the
stingrays like he's he's probably making
especially for that area making bank and
he ships all over the world yeah yeah
how much does a flower horn got explain
explain the flower horn you know it's
it's it's different like animal to
animal um
with what's kind of funny and
interesting
the stingray guy so what he does as a
full-time job is he actually
uh like does car like
uh i don't know how to describe it
modifications on car like really
high-end custom
mods because in singapore i mean even
own a car in singapore is like expensive
yeah just the taxes for like
a really cheap honda civic luxury tax
yeah 50
percent it's not yeah triple the cost of
the car so he does that full time and i
asked him like well what do you make
more money from like the cars or the
stingrays is like the stingrays
and the stingrays is just like a side
thing why does he just stingray full
time i don't know i was like why don't
you just like open up like a whole
or even facility i i'm not sure
um but he i think maybe he just really
likes the stability in the cars what's
some of the craziest stuff that you've
seen overseas in terms of the business
aspect of
of this like the stingrays that's
incredible
the flower horns i would imagine that's
i haven't seen that video but would be
even
crazier than that like what else have
you seen um
i've seen like some markets some like
wholesale markets where in asia like on
certain days of the week
they'll basically um like the there was
one called the chatuchak market in
thailand in bangkok
where just like hundreds of vendors like
farmers
like individual breeders like the
stinger guy clownfish they'll show up
they'll basically like sit on the floor
of like a parking lot
and and just like have fish out on
display for people to come pick
up but then a lot of those people are
like exporters that sometimes export
them to the united states or other
countries
um sometimes they're just like fish
stores but like um i've been in some
markets that are like
they go for acres like we're talking
about like acres and acres are just like
the most exotic
fish some of which many of which are
even illegal in the united states to
keep
uh which makes it so much more
interesting for my american viewers is
to see fish like arowanas
which um are they why are those because
i used to see those in fish stores
graham i'm surprised you don't have
marijuana that's a that's a fish that i
could call fish
it is a very cool fish i would have to
have an arowana tank now macy wants a
clown fish tank
does she yeah yeah clownfish
it's the entry point for a lot of people
in the hobby or clownfish but um
arowana so the arowana fish is also
known as the dragon fish
and in asia it's like a sign of wealth
and fortune and like prestige oh we
gotta get one
it's dude there i don't you got to flash
a photo of them they're just yeah
they're still a little
[ __ ] and um they're big they're shiny
and
um they're actually they became so like
popular that people they basically like
fished them
out of ex to extinction i didn't know
this and yeah so they're
they're con i think the reason that
they're illegal in the united states
asian arowana
uh is because they are on like the
society's two or three list
considered endangered so you're not
you're not allowed to have them here in
canada you can have them um
but yeah so like seeing those fish and
those fishing go for
um hundreds of thousands of dollars you
know i've seen arowana fish where
they're like yeah this one's like
50k 80k 100k so like
um i was just my most recent trip uh was
japan and there they're crazy over koi
so koi
uh fish which most people here just go
to like their botanical gardens and see
swimming like it's a koi fish
over in uh japan that fish is like
again another just massive symbol of
like uh good luck
and so there was a koi fish in 2018 that
sold for 1.8 million dollars
it was the most expensive fish ever sold
um why why was that fish so expensive it
was like
so they do these koi uh competitions uh
and they do this for every fish
um you know clown fish flower horn and
we
um all the different fish they have
competitions for them to see you know
because the breeders want to know like
who whose fish are the best and that
also will
help dictate the price on a certain fish
so
um but like koi fish there's so many
different breeders they enter these
competitions
and this fish i think it uh
won grand champion like two or three
years in a row
and it was just like massive this
gargantuan was like
i think like i think it was like two
three feet
i mean at that size it looks like a
little pig yeah it was like the size of
like a small pig
so the size the body shape the
coloration the pattern
the colors because um all those things
have to do with like
the perfect koi and um believe it or not
the guy who bought it
the fish ended up dying a year i think a
year later no
why it just i don't know it just i don't
i don't think there's a lot of
information on that
i don't know why this is worth
so much that's the fish so it's so
beautiful yeah so it's just good to me
man
jack's like i want more i mean it looks
good but but i like if i saw that
i wouldn't think that's like the most
expensive
yeah i wouldn't think that's the best in
show screenshot so
the reason that one uh there's actually
a few different types
but the red and white varieties are
worth
are like considered the best uh
and worth the most because red and white
it's like the
the colors on the japanese flag even
yeah they're just like those are the
colors that they
they value um wait so so when you say
it died you were talking about the fish
fish died yeah
all right first thing i thought we
should but the owner the owner um you're
like who gets the fish now
wow i mean the fish is big
yeah it's a massive face is big
yeah i mean it's a good looking koi fish
like i've seen koi fish before like at
the local chinese restaurant or
something like that that looks like a
nice koi fish
but i i don't know if i would say that's
like a two million dollar wow
to the average person you know they you
wouldn't know um yeah you wouldn't
but to so many people who are like
dedicated their lives to
these sub sections of the hobby yeah
it's like everything to them
no the fish died do you know why the
fish
is it do do they have a life koi could
live a long time
so yeah it was nine years old when it
was sold
yeah i mean i don't think there's a lot
of information on why exactly it died i
don't
i don't know maybe the owner didn't want
to reveal that or something i'm not sure
at least to my knowledge i don't know
but
um i i will tell you like a lot of fish
have pretty long lifespans i mean koi
fish can live like 20 to 30 years on
average
um there's like there's legend rumors
that there's a koi fish that is live to
be like a few hundred years old
that's not typical but even like um a
lot of marine fish
like a lot of the fish you have i know
macy was asking yesterday or the other
day
um and they were really surprised by the
life span of like a clown fish i mean
clowns
live 15 to 20 years i didn't know that
yeah even in a in your aquarium i know a
lot of different hobbyists who have been
able to keep a clown fish for 15
20 years so yeah wow they have longer
life spans than i think a lot of people
think i think that's because
most people get the goldfish that will
get sick and die within like a few days
or six months or something but when you
buy a 1.8 million
fish do you buy it with you must buy it
with the intention of breeding it right
because otherwise let's say you buy at
1.8 million
you only got like let's say five to ten
years with the fish
probably let's say 10 years 180 thousand
dollars a year to own the fish
yeah i think it's just a flex like i
think it's all it is i think the same
way elon musk had like so much money
yeah i think the same way elon musk will
just blow
you know crazy amount of money on
something to fly i mean that's just what
he did have you ever got bit by a fish
um
and you like bled no it's funny now you
guys are gonna be like i told you so but
my dad got bit by one of my piranhas
[Music]
that you say is safe it was an accident
right it was probably didn't mean to
and that's that's it just thought his
hand was food right
and you're actually right that's exactly
what it was my dad just the way he feeds
them was just like leaving his fingers
in there like holding on to the food
if you play with fire you're gonna get
burned so and that was
that was but uh i personally have never
gotten
like stung or bitten by anything crazy
and i hope not to because yeah but most
of the time it's on accident i mean
that's that's something else like
so when i was in asia one of the biggest
projects that i did
was um like a a couple videos on sharks
and what's happening to sharks right now
because each year over
near 100 million sharks are killed 100
million
100 million is that for the finished
finch spin suit for shark fins
that many sure 100 million how is that
possible
and i thought the same thing i was like
that must just be like grossly inflated
yeah the when you think about china
and their population it's like and then
you take like a food that we have here
in america and you
like hamburgers right yeah and for them
shark fin soup was just like for the
longest
it's on the decline now with more
awareness and stuff but it's still like
it's being sold
dude i saw this oh sorry go for it well
and yeah i was just gonna say like it's
um
it's a much bigger issue than a lot of
people think how do you oh yeah
i was just going to say i saw this video
i remember like back in middle school
where they like wrangled a bunch of
dolphins oh
what's that yeah that video was horrific
it was
so tragic yeah i feel bad i've seen some
of those fishing videos where like they
they take up the fish
yeah there's like something that gets
caught in there like nothing it's not
necessarily a dolphin but it's something
that
and it's just flopping it's flopping on
the deck and nobody's like put it back
in the water
it blows it's just it's so easy just
just do that
just do that and fish could live and
they just they just don't care
yeah i mean for them it's just
considered i mean obviously it's their
job those fishermen
um and it's it's food for them and that
was something i learned
over in asia as well is like we
you know i did a whole basic whole video
on the shark fishermen who
um are are collecting these sharks and
is like well they're just
literally doing it to provide for their
family it's like that's all they have
so isn't there is there aren't there
other foods that you could eat besides
shark or is it just like that's that's
easy to catch
they get money for it because in in
china shark fin soup is like a delicacy
it's a luxury so they get like a premium
for catching a shark versus a fish so
they're like
encouraged to kill sharks it's the same
thing for the meat
market here you know for for meat
production it's like you just like
people like eating steaks that's why we
keep making it
yeah but at least with with steak i mean
the the cows are
um and that's a whole nother thing but
they're they're farm
raised right like they're they're born
to be
to be concerned oh true like the sharks
in the ocean it's not
it's not like that and something
interesting too is like sharks a lot of
different sharks
sometimes they won't be ready to have
babies like they won't be ready to breed
for
10 15 until they're like 10 15 years old
so if you kill too many sharks before
they reach that age like
you really like i mean they say that
sharks won't be around in
50 years wow yeah just be due to the
crazy overfishing
of of them and there's a lot of there's
a lot of marine life like that though
there really is what are the other sides
of uh the aquarium world like this that
you could tell us that might not
might paint a worse picture like like
the sharks are importing
illegal fish and coral yeah what can we
at least bring awareness to so that
now more people know that this is
happening i mean i'd say first and
foremost
the some of those like bigger marine
species like sharks and
um and whales and all sorts of those
those bigger marine life because you
know they are the top of the food chain
and so if you take the apex predator
away which is the shark i mean the whole
everything underneath just like
starts just going um but for me like one
of the things with
the with the hobby is that i've been
really excited to see is
um aquariums is is an amazing hobby
and yeah there are a lot of fish that
are imported um
from from different places in the world
but
um there's also like a massive effort
right now
it's not an effort it's happening of
captive breeding fish
for aquariums so like all throughout the
united states and and as you saw with
the stingray video
people are breeding these animals and
with the purpose of
you know taking less from the ocean so
that's amazing um
and there's also um another i mean
it's there's a lot of um you've seen
sort of the rise of a lot of
environmentalists
like just coming down and coming in on
everything
and i feel like maybe the aquarium hobby
has like felt that a little bit
but there's just there are so many fish
now being
bred in captivity so it's a really
positive thing and
also coral too yep people are farming
you know plants for their aquariums
coral for the aquariums um and it's it's
a lot better for the fish too because
then those fish
and those animals are raised under you
know
certain conditions that allow them to
live healthier and happier and longer
lives in aquariums yeah that's what i
like
like uh andrew sin city corals shout out
link down below in the description but
he's grown all this stuff in his huge
like 600 gallon tank
just breaks off a little piece puts it
in my tank and one day
i could break off a piece for somebody
else jack when you set up your reef tank
i'll break off a little piece i'll give
that to you thank you i'll give you a
good price too
so let's go back to your business right
now so
you decided to give this a shot full
time
how was that transition for you um well
it was exciting
um you know it was something that i
never thought was gonna be possible like
i said
my junior year of college even actually
up until my senior year of college i
remember sitting in my dorm room
thinking
this is never going to work like this
would be my dream job but i'm never
going to be able to
go to my parents and tell them i want to
do this full time
and then after my viral video you know
things changed i was able to
immediately like start understanding the
whole
algorithm how that works you know just
the whole business side of it
and i picked up on it really fast i
think you know as a combination of me
also just maturing as a person like
finishing college
right and um and
and you know i've been doing youtube a
long time but i was also like living my
life
and growing up and like doing all the
normal kid
things so i wasn't like intensely
focused on
how do i like crack this algorithm i was
just like by
sheer like not chance but by
coincidence maybe like i was hitting a
lot of different
like good things for the algorithm and
like how to do it
like a like my thumbnails and stuff like
we're pretty good and like sometimes i
have videos that would blow up
um you know a couple of couple hundred
thousand views but
once i was able to like get a bunch of
other youtubers
to like show me how much they were
making and like
why they were making that and for me to
realize okay you need a lot of views
like you need volume right
to get you know for for all these like
the little the money to add up
um that's when you know i i just like
put it all together
and i was like okay i can do this what
did you oh wait what did you want to do
originally um well my original plan yeah
my original plan like
from high school was i i mean i really
wanted to play professional basketball
not in the nba like overseas so my dad
uh is from greece and so like
you know a dream of mine was to like go
play in greece for a couple years
and be by like some of my family out
there and just like learn the language
more and just like
just you know enjoy that but college
basketball i mean it was it was great
it was fun but you know by year four
just all sports in general they're very
political i gotten very burnt out of
that and just
um and i was i accepted the opportunity
to
youtube very happily you know i was like
wow okay this is
something very exciting and also is
happening so fast that i didn't want to
like miss it
you know my channel went from like 60
000 to like 160 000 in
a month or two and so i and i think
momentum is one of the most
important things so i wanted to
capitalize on that momentum
and you know basically about a month
before i
graduated i hired my first editor
cameraman
and just and went got straight to work
basically
how much were you making at the time
that you graduated college
um like what was my final like adsense
like months yeah yeah of college
i think i was probably somewhere like in
the like six
six thousand seven thousand so if you're
making six to seven thousand dollars a
month i'm sure telling your parents that
you wanted to do that full time out of
college
it wasn't like a very difficult
conversation no it
wasn't it was definitely like you know
they can see the number and say
hey this is very like yeah
and and they knew that that's what i
wanted to do i have just the most
supportive
parents even from as you know like my
mom going with the saltwater crime from
the beginning like
they just they they they knew that's
what i wanted to do and um
and they were just like very happy to
see me like doing it and also being able
to earn good money doing it i think my
parents
would have been okay with me like going
out on a limb and trying to
you know whatever i would want to do in
my life if i made no money from in the
beginning like
i have the type of parents that would
encourage me to still go for if that's
what i was passionate about
um so i'm really lucky for that um but
also like one thing that i didn't
mention was
aqua shella and that start we
we started aqua shallow aquarium
festival my junior year of college
and um you gotta explain what aqua
shella is yeah okay so this is an
interesting story
so basically throughout college i was
like getting paid to go to different
aquarium conventions
to do like their media to do advertising
for them and
i you know after about two or three of
them it just sort of got like boring to
me
and i thought hey there's got to be like
a better way than like this
old traditional convention right so um
my friend and i we saw there was there
was actually an aquarium event
that that year for whatever reason it
was like i think it was mismanaged or
something
decided to leave chicago chicago being
my hometown i thought
there's a massive opportunity here right
like they've been doing this event for
five six years
there's they've obviously built up this
market i'm not don't know why they're
leaving but
hey like why don't we capitalize this so
um
now my business partner but um my good
friend at the time his name's sean hale
so he works as a manufacturer in the
industry
and because he had been attending all
these events as a manufacturer
you know buying sponsorships to the
events buying booths to the event
he had that side of the industry on
lockdown he had lots of experience
in that world and he's a lot older than
i am actually
so he's 36 so he just been in business
for a long time and had a lot of
also a good experience and just all you
know corporate
uh and other facets of business but we
started this event
my junior year we're like okay
we we need a name so i was like we need
some really cool name
and coachella was happening around that
time naturally i was like
why don't we do like aquacella no no i
get the name that's a good name
did it before no so this is what
happened yeah but
you might not have gotten it because
what happened was about a month or two
i'm thinking of cello
cello like a cello like a like a musical
instead like a cello
i don't know a month or two in we
actually got a cease and desist from
from coachella saying like we have a
chella trademark
are you serious yeah and we but we had
like used that first two months of
marketing like blown up
because coachella was happening that
time and everyone was like aquachella
like this is great we got like 10 000
uh people on our facebook page like
right away so it blew up like from the
start and with the marketing that i put
behind it
um it just like it was pretty close to
like a
interesting success what did i do for
the marketing yeah no what did you do
afterwards it gave you a season
did you try to fight it at all so we
pivoted we're like no we're not going to
like fight this guy
call it something else like isn't there
another way to spell chella well we so
we
pivoted an a with a little you know yeah
we pivoted
to we pivoted to aqua shella which
actually ended up being i think
better yeah yeah so sort of a blessing
but then we've gotten the marketing from
aqua
so we changed it to aqua shell and
basically for the next eight months i
was
studying abroad at the time so me and my
business partner were on like
different time zones like big time so i
was staying up to like
i was supposed to be studying abroad not
playing basketball that was like
supposed to be my break
like just being with my friends out
there like traveling in europe
instead i sat in my flat in london and
just got to work
and i just started grinding every day on
this event aqua shella
and i everything i'd learned up until
that point
um you know i just started pouring into
the marketing
i was up probably most nights i'd say
like
the average at six a.m then i'd go to
bed for like three hours
my classmates would like wake me up at
nine a.m to go to class i did that for
like
pretty much the entire two and a half
month study abroad
term and um it was it was difficult but
i knew that i was building something
that had like this massive potential um
so then my junior year i finished
i finished the study abroad went back
home that summer i just kept working on
it with my business partner for like the
next three months
all the way up until our first event
which was in september um
we did our first event we had like three
i think it was like 3 500 people come
almost 4 000 people attend the first one
in chicago
we it was like you guys seen fire
festival like the documentary
you've seen it did you see it no it's a
it's a
it's a show man you gotta watch you
gotta watch it just gets crazier
and crazier and crazier some of these
things that they say
for those who are unaware they they sold
out this event claiming to be like
the top event in the world people were
paying like five to twenty five
thousand dollars per ticket to go to the
fire festival that was going to be
on pablo escobar's old island but it
turned out to be a giant scam they got
there and they were like hurricane
tense instead of like in instead of like
you know
luxury campsites is like oh and and then
what went viral
someone posted on twitter supposed to be
like this hand chef
curated meal from like the best chef in
the world
and it was this picture of a styrofoam
plate
with two pieces of bread on it yeah and
like a piece of bologna and cheese
no so they actually held it but
you shouldn't be laughing it shouldn't
be laughing at this but they get there
and it's
raining literally it's raining yeah and
it's like all these like
all these influencers like for you know
that paid
exorbitant amounts of money to go there
being these like cabanas and it's just
like a hurricane and it's like chaos
nothing set up and like basically the
whole thing was just like being called i
felt called off
so bad because the locals were really
like this was big business for them
because they don't get tourists
yeah and so to have you know hundreds of
really wealthy people flying and they're
spending money
they were paid like you know millions of
dollars to set up for this thing
and it turned out that they had worked
really hard they didn't get paid
i mean it was horrible who threw it uh
what was his name
uh it was just some it was some guy
probably better not give him
exposure but anyway this guy who's had a
history of uh
over-promising under-delivering taking
money shutting down businesses getting
investors
all excited basically he basically took
all the money spent it on himself
and then just whatever was left over
tried tried to make this as best as he
could
yeah he took like five million dollars
and then like try to use like
50 000 to put on the event it didn't
work yeah but um so
that guy that whole thing that's exactly
like i couldn't relate ever to anything
more in my life
that's how setting up aqua shella felt
really yes to that degree
like how much money you make um you
bought the lamborghini and
dude i would watch the gold rolex i wish
i'm kidding
it was yeah but it was it was chaotic
yeah it was chaotic putting on events
of this of that magnitude for thousands
of people how many people were involved
in just you and
me and sean we were like really that
first event it was just like
us yeah it's you needed like 20 people
on that and we just
we do yeah a lot of things you forget
like parking
oh yeah security food like all the
little things that you would never even
consider like who's gonna check the
tickets in the front
it's how many people do you need yeah
and so like we almost died
like just from like exhaustion and and
just
like stress i think i think i must have
aged like
five years just in those few months but
we put on the event
we like barely and like the event went
well like
obviously there were the hiccups it's
like the first one but
we like just barely managed to like get
out of it like
and be okay and at the end of the day
we didn't really walk home with much
money like it was
we didn't walk on with much money it was
like we had a little bit of money left
in the bank
we had a lot of assets though to like
the infrastructure for the facility like
the whole set
and everything and we had proven out
this concept because it was like
a very new thing all the all the indus
the whole industry was like
what is this going to be it's like is
this some brave or is this an aquarium
convention right
they didn't quite understand it um and
so we were able to like prove
the concept like hey this new way of
teaching people about aquariums getting
people interested
um you know and making it an event where
like anyone could attend and they would
just like love it they'd have a
great time and just think it was like
potentially like the most fascinating
thing
so that was like the whole idea behind
it uh and aquacello basically is it's an
aquarium convention
but it's it incorporates elements of
like a music or art festival and there's
like
this there's a massive art installations
aquatic themed
like with like uv uh paint so like under
black light everything's glowing
and it's just like it's it's a way to
get a lot of people interested in the
hobby
a lot of the industry they weren't sure
about it but all of the good
deeds i'd done for companies in the
years previous
and also my business partner with you
know same with him
it all came back and in that moment we
were like cash in on all that good karma
a lot of people helped support that
first one
but we didn't make a lot of money on for
the first one so
then my business partner was like dude
we just worked eight months
on this event unpaid and we still we
didn't really make much
like what i don't know what you want to
do and i was like
we now that we have all of the assets we
have the whole infrastructure the set
and everything
all we have to do is take this pick it
up
move it to a different city and run it
there and we should be
we should make money that this time and
he's like you're crazy you're telling me
like after eight months and he works
his own full-time job as a manufacturer
he's like you want to you want to do
this
again that was absolute hell and you're
telling me to do it again for another
six months
so yeah let's do it in your hometown and
so he's from dallas so we did our second
one in dallas
six months later and that was my senior
year of college
keep in mind i'm still playing college
basketball while i'm working on my
youtube channel
aqua shella and um and school
yeah so yeah i mean my senior year
it was we actually lined up the dates
perfectly so that the event was going to
happen over spring break
so i had off from school and um
and we we did our second one in dallas
and it went
it just went crazy like we were on good
morning texas
we had like 7 000 people show up people
were like
moms people were just coming up to me
like crying like begging to get in we
had sold out the fire marshal
shut us down because we're like over
capacity wow it was just like
it was insane it was it was it was crazy
and um and we took a whole team that
time we
and we had grown a little bit more of a
team we had some of the artists we had
like some more staff we'd actually it's
really interesting
after our first one we had someone reach
out they wanted to buy a franchise
in new orleans they're like we want to
do this in new orleans like will you
sell us one
uh my business partner was like kind of
entertaining i was like no can you
say how much they offered uh yeah i
think they wanted like it was like 35k
or 40k for it but it's just the
franchise and then you would get to keep
a portion of the profits too
yeah i think there would have been like
a royalty or something yeah but i was
like hey no i don't trust anyone else to
run this event the way
we do so we actually took that guy and
we turned him into our
we brought him onto our team he's
actually one of our show managers now
and um so that's been great but yeah we
expanded our team
and um the dallas one um
i mean the line was insane to try to get
it i mean it was
went on for so long and uh but we did
make money
and we made a good amount of money and
how much
every once how much we made like um
i'd say that first aqua shallow we made
like
um like almost a hundred thousand split
between you and your
yeah almost a hundred thousand and and
that's that's including the assets that
you
including the assets which and we had
actually built up even more assets
because we had like built onto this side
even more um
so yeah i mean i basically then i went
back
to college for my last two months of
college and that was a really
interesting two months for me because
like it was i went back to college
immediately after being like submerged
in this like
um i think you know how it feels when
you can't go back you can't yeah
you're surrounded by like children
correct it's like
what's going on this is weird yes you're
like
oh my god like the conversations that a
lot of my friends were having i went out
to the bar that weekend and like people
you know susie's like talking about the
hockey player that won't give her a look
yeah and i'm like did you see what last
week was what spencer said man
and he's like dude i got better things
right
yeah exactly and i just it was really
hard for me because i i
really like i couldn't relate with
anyone at college anymore like all these
kids were doing these
not internships but like internships or
like gearing up for like
and i was just like in two months you
guys are graduating yeah like what are
you guys doing like
get it together man like you're talking
about the hockey player that won't give
you that won't look at you like
you have much more important things to
worry about
like so you know that was that was kind
of interesting
um and you know it was also like i had
um
i was i was sort of depressed for like a
week after that event because
well i was depressed and i was happy but
you know uh
you spent so much time like months and
months just focusing on this
one day of the year how it's going to go
and then it just happens
and when it's over just like it's over
did you miss it or no it was like just
like you know i
this is going to be weird that i'm
comparing myself to this or what but
you know that feeling that like
postpartum when women like get have
don't know that
no no you don't i've heard of have you
heard it yes i've heard of it have you
heard of postpartum and like women
have their baby yeah and they're just
like they feel like emotion the flood of
hormones and yes right
they feel like empty though because like
they were carrying something for
nine months and then it's just not there
anymore and like they feel like
something's missing
um i've actually heard it on a lot of
different podcasts like
business owners who sell their
businesses for like 20 100 million
dollars whatever it's like
the saddest day of their lives because
they're just like
i got nothing to do tomorrow yeah like i
just sold my company like so they got
100 million in their pocket but like
they have no purpose so like i i sort of
felt that a little bit
and we actually now have coined it
because a lot of it was it wasn't just
me like a lot of our staff
got it and we coined it the aqua shell
of blues
we had like grown-ass men with like yeah
we're like supposed to be doing like uh
with power tools like crying after the
event because they're like
i'm gonna miss you all like this was so
crazy and so much fun and like
so yeah it's just it's become a really
big team effort
and um and and yeah when when i got back
to college and that check hit my bank
account
it was after basically a whole year of
working on it
um that along with my youtube channel
finally clicking
it was like everything had just like
come together and i was like i just
remember sitting in my dorm room and
and i was like kind of emotional because
it just was
like i just figured it out yeah and this
whole time i didn't know what i was
going to do after school
necessarily and i that was my dream so
how many do you host now
we actually this year have expanded our
to our third one
in orlando so in besides if you don't
count the pandemic year
in two years we've grown to three one
chicago one in dallas and one in orlando
so the one in orlando is coming up june
12th and 13th
uh 2021 and it's gonna be crazy and then
dallas you're telling me is on halloween
yeah this year we've moved dallas to be
on halloween and we're gonna call it
aqua shellaween
and so it's it's crazy we should go i
think i want to dude it's going to be
cool because
i think we're going to be able to pull
like incorporate elements of a haunted
house
into what is already very like
has a bit of that that element to it so
i think we'll be able to pull like a
really ridiculous crowd
you should get a clown fish as like the
orange and the black
and look something like that or it was
what is it the achilles tang
yeah achilles tang yeah well we i don't
know if you've seen
like some of the promotional like stuff
we have but not for the halloween we
bought these
massive inflatables for like to put
outside the event spaces
so we bought this like 30 foot by 30
foot
inflatable clownfish that just like sits
outside the event it's filled with air
and and yeah i mean there's a lot of
different things
like that where my business partner has
been like are you sure you want to spend
you know that kind of money on something
like that i'm like yes like this is how
you get people excited about
an event right this is how you uh you
you should tell people like and i think
that also resonates with people i mean i
think it's
most the time when when you when you see
people putting a lot of effort into
something like you're way more willing
to buy into it so
yeah you know what uh george reminds me
of uh
the strad man of reef tanks
dude i actually see that yeah i actually
see that strad man
you're the strad man of aquariums tell
me about strat man you don't know the
strat man
wow very positive very genuine yeah uh
yeah the stride man has one of the
largest car channels
okay out there i'm not the biggest car
guy really okay so
that's why i don't know but yeah but but
of the car niche
you have like doug demiro uh you have
another one daily driven exotics and a
few other ones but but strad man's like
near the top
and for the reef aquarium i feel like
you got the
you're the strat man of the reef
aquarium watch the strat mate you're
going to see
the resemblance like very the way that
you talk and carry yourself yeah yeah
cool it's it's it's accomplished it's a
i hope this
man is a cool guy yeah he's extremely
likable he is yeah
uh so can you walk us through the
numbers right now of your business
of uh my youtube business or my
everything yeah
everything you're comfortable discussing
they want the numbers yeah um
well i mean youtube we'll start with
youtube
i mean it's nice because i've built this
uh foundation
my audience is is education based right
like teaching people how to set up
aquariums so
uh because i've done like everything
really um because i took all i always
took the extra steps to like
fact check everything i was saying and
make sure like everything was the proper
way
to to educate people a lot of aquarium
brands really respect my channel which
isn't
that's not always common with you know
animal pet channels
um so i mean as far as sponsorships go
i've been able to like land some
these like good good long term
sponsorships um it's tough because like
aquarium brands don't
always they're not gonna like want to
pay as much as
like a big court like big corporate
brand would uh
because they just like they're not used
to working with influencers
right so sometimes you really gotta like
i mean that's that's been uh also part
of like what took me i think so long to
start generating more money for my
channel um
was just for them to like realize that
versus maybe some other bigger companies
realize it quicker
but i mean what do you want to know
uh just like could you just give us a
call
yeah we could see your analytics or just
like an estimation do you want to just
see it yeah
all right you tell me now it's crazy
like aquariums like it doesn't have the
cpm you guys have which i'm very jealous
of because
sometimes i feel like i am working very
very hard for like
let's see these consistent views
oh man look at that are you going to
like my my yearly
yeah yeah well just for the last 28
it's almost it's it's like same views
every day that's really good
same subscribers every day the
ah that's cpm yeah it's just not
it's it's not nowhere near yours it's
like 25
a quarter yeah uh you guys
you trust me you do not know how good
you have it because i think
most of youtube is has my cpm i'd say
like 75 percent of youtube is
this what i have so you guys really are
i don't know if you like you just get
grow not grossly overpaid but like you
just get paid so much more for the same
amount of work
that i do well this is uh this is
interesting 30
of your audience is in the united states
for us
it's like 85 percent yeah now that so
that went
down my u.s base went down a little bit
just because like when i went overseas
for
almost a year yeah doing different
videos um
philippines that's why your cpm is going
to be a lot lower though
yeah yeah i mean if the cpm before i
went
and i did all these trips was wasn't too
far off though
and i know aquarium other aquarium
youtubers have a very similar cpm to me
that don't make it like travel content
yeah but
it's a it's the audience demographics so
they have like similar
audience demographics no i'm saying like
percent usa no i'm saying like they're
probably like
80 usa and they have the same cpm like
it is the topic trust me it is i've like
triple checked with
pretty much every aquarium youtuber and
i mean my cpm is what they make as well
it's not just the international thing
so but in addition to that then you also
have sponsorships supplementing that
yeah so i have some sponsorships that i
have on the yearly side
and again like some of those some of
those i'll sacrifice on the dollar
amount just because there's like a lot
of good synergy with like what how what
they can do for me
right like they can provide me with
tanks or like
you know lots of travel costs or just
like do you want to give a shout out
uh one of my biggest sponsors is fritz
aquatics and that's
the company that my business partner for
aqua shella
uh that's the company he works for okay
so i gotta say you sent me
the fritz uh turbo start yes start my
tank
amazing product insane insane you sent
me an entire
gallon that was shipped in like this
temperature controlled
box yeah to keep it cool and i dumped in
this bacteria that like
turbo starts the tank as a cycle like
it's it's the bacteria that you'll
normally wait weeks to generate that you
could start almost within like a few
days
they claim that you can put fish in
there the same day
as turbo start they claim that because
the um
the bacteria they culture in their
facility in dallas is like
and they ship it refrigerated overnight
it's like so
dense and it's just like so concentrated
i put this in the tank
it's just clouded the tank for
temporarily obviously it's all bacteria
but it's their most popular product
and um and it's it's like a very easy
product for me to promote
as well because like everyone when
they're setting up tanks like needs
turbo start you can even throw turbo
start in your existing tank just like
add the bacteria levels uh to like bring
them up yeah so you can't you can never
overdose it either so
but like fritz aquatics is is my longest
one
um and the way i met sean who is the
business partner for aqua shelly he
um it's so funny so he was a sponsor for
like
a different aquarium convention i
remember he was like
attending it as with like as a sponsor
with a booth
vendor booth and the that show asked me
to
interview him since he was a platinum
sponsor and i was on doing the marketing
so like we still have this video which
is crazy to watch now like
four i think four years ago like us just
sitting on some like fritz salt buckets
like just talking i never you know we
both didn't realize at the time that
would turn into
a friendship that would then also later
turn into now the biggest aquarium event
in north america which is aqua shella so
i got to try the salt too
do the salt and you see reef crystals
yeah it's a big yeah it's okay
it's a big upgrade from reef crystals
briefcase just is uh
you know a lot of the salts are very
similar but the bigger difference with
fritz
salt is like it'll mix clear like really
quickly
and there's no residue in the container
um
it's like very uh it's like almost like
a powder okay
so yeah and i've used their salt my
tanks for for years and
they've been able to grow their company
what's so interesting
is now everyone wants to like now every
manufacturer i think really wants to do
marketing and advertising with me fritz
aquatics got in like from the very start
because
i don't know what i mean sean saw
something in me as like a
young college kid when my channel was at
like 10 000 subscribers
and he was willing to invest and um
and um you know so i'm very thankful and
i'm very loyal to that brand for that
reason
we've grown together it's like uh it's
sort of like david dobrik and see geek
like my brand like with fritz is just
they're synonymous cool so yeah it's one
of my favorite it's called favorite
sponsor so you have
the youtube ad revenue yeah i got my
youtube sponsorships mm-hmm
aqua aqua it's taking place once a year
three times a year three times a year
three times a year yeah how how would
you
divide it if you had like a yeah what
percentages would you allocate to
different income sources i'd say like
50 of my revenue is
youtube a third of my revenue is
uh aqua shella and the rest is like
merch sponsorships like in like
miscellaneous
cool you were telling me too that you're
diversifying into real estate
yeah so that's that's what i've been
doing with all the money
that i'm making from youtube aqua shella
i've just
really i've been putting it almost
exclusively into real estate
why real estate uh well my dad
is um he's a real estate investor and
he's also just a serial entrepreneur
so he's been in so many different like
businesses in his life
um i should i should just say he's a
investor because he doesn't only invest
in real estate i guess he'll invest in
kind of like you you reminded me a lot
of him when you're
talking about like oh i bought this car
because like it was such a good deal
that's exactly how my dad is like my dad
has bought some just the most
random things and got into some very
interesting business ventures
just because they were like very good
entry deals right like he could
he stole them essentially so um yeah i
mean
we were raised sort of with like uh
to have with that entrepreneur spirit
but also i think like with a little bit
of like a mercenary mentality
like our dad always pushed us like to
make money like you know
he's an immigrant from greece he came
from nothing
and i mean that was obviously very
inspiring for all my brothers and i
to to see you know for him to go if you
see
like the village that he's from in
greece and the fact that he was like
walking around at 10 years old there
with like no shoes
like i don't even think he has a story
that he didn't
try a banana until he was like 15 or
something like
it's then for him to come to the america
and live the american dream
you know he's he's uh put a lot of that
into us and
so you know we were born to you know
raised with this idea like
you know america is an amazing place
with so much opportunity
go go get it you know like take
advantage of it it's also something i've
been able to realize just
traveling to as many countries as i've
been to because like i think now i'm at
25 25 different countries and um
yeah when you really when you go out
there and you see different parts of the
world you'll come back to
realize just how how much opportunity
there is here and there's a lot of
people that say the american dream is
dead i mean it's not what it was maybe
for immigrants like
20 30 years ago right with like the
doors wide open to certain industries
but like
still america so much more opportunity
than
the majority of other countries how were
you able to manage real estate
doing all that at the same time do you
want rental properties flips
um it's actually it's it's all
commercial real estate
so um i mean
my younger brother is actually is he
he's he's here where is he my younger
brother your younger brother's here i do
have a younger brother and his name is
yani i heard a rumor
that if you say yanni three times in a
row
he shows up let's try it ready
yanni
hey guys what's going on this is my
younger brother
this is my younger brother yanni he's he
uh hey
he's two years younger than me but uh he
has a rope
he's like right yeah what kind of rope
is that it looks like versace
it looks like versace it's not as
expensive
because of the amount of money i lost at
a casino this weekend but yeah
uh it turned out it's my last friend's
21st birthday so i came to vegas and
it's good timing because
we've got a real estate guru right here
cool that's what we're getting into
i want to hear about the real estate
between you so what have you bought
so the niche that we found is industrial
properties
and basically what we do is tour a lot
of them
and make really low offers so we make
really good deals happen somewhere where
we can find a single tenant
for an industrial property so like auto
repair shops
car washes garages and
they're really just low maintenance
properties so it's perfect for him
and it's perfect really for for anyone
yeah anyone it's not like
it's exclusive to anyone but um
one of the reasons we like these like
commercial that niche that yani just
said is
like he said they're very low
maintenance so what we found is that
uh if you buy like a commercial piece of
real estate with
an elevator you are like you are going
to constantly be getting phone calls
about the elevator not working or like
the air conditioning units are like not
working
like there's as you know there's a lot
of different problems and come up with
real estate
uh like and if you you can't
you can't predict them and sometimes
they are can even be very expensive
fixes right so we realize that like
garages
are the type like it's an interesting
property type because
the people who are using garages are
mechanics
they're handymen so if their air
conditioning unit goes out or anything
isn't working
they don't call you they'll just fix it
themselves and so it's like
one of the lowest i think it may be the
lowest
maintenance type of real estate to buy
and that's why we were so attracted to
it
but yeah um like george was talking
about earlier
our dad has um
he's like involved in almost every
business you could pro
possibly imagine and through 40 years of
doing real estate
he's just got so many headaches from so
many different things so
finding this um this niche where you
really
don't even see your tenant for a year or
two after you sign a lease it just
worked out perfect
for him because he can put the money in
and not really have to
to manage the properties which is also
some
um we have a there's another um niche
that we're looking forward to it's like
foreclosure properties where i think a
lot of people
want to look for like flips but uh
something we're thinking about doing
which we can't because the covid right
now
and the uh the courts are closed we
can't get
eviction notices to get people out
because we want to rent them out for
section 8 housing yeah so how many
properties do you have now
i have three so i have three garages uh
i have five garages how much how much
you guys making from this uh
each garage is about i think we net
about so
they're not leases and the um tenant
usually pays
5 000 rent is what we look for and then
what's your take home after that after
uh well i guess you're not paying taxes
or anything on that but
do you do you have to pay insurance no
so actually the you pay insurance
well they pay the rent and the property
taxes right is this triple net
yeah so we basically i mean it's about
net 5000 per property a month
to yeah you have luggage yeah i mean
we put about 25 down so what's the cash
flow like on these
oh it's very good you're looking at each
year like
sometimes like 20 to 30 percent
potentially
it's it's like okay so so on five you're
walking away with about
2200 a month net to you in your pocket
i would say it's close to like three
let's say it's close like
three grand a month per property yeah so
three times
nine thousand dollars a month from rent
in these properties net
25 like so it's a great return because
each property i think mine mine the
average cost of mine is about between
like 175
to like two like three hundred usually
like 150 and 300 thousand dollars is
like the average
property cost and then you take home
about 60
60 000 a year so that's
really high roi what areas well so we're
doing it in chicago but these properties
exist
everywhere which is really cool wait how
is that wait
so let's say 300 grand it's renting at 5
000
a month triple net so five what is it 60
so you're getting a 33 yeah roi you have
to understand
yeah so you have to understand how hard
we work for these properties so there's
a lot of people that will go out and
they'll buy like
um they'll buy like a lot
well they'll be very aggressive right on
like a really nice
looking piece of real estate or
something that looks really good
there's always a ton of uh buyers even
right now at the housing market like
people
are like not overpaying but giving like
10
20 over asking price right so it's the
same idea with like most
real estate however what we do is like
we play the waiting game and so what
we'll do is like we'll put in an offer
which is like very very low sometimes
solo that they'll
bad mouth us so get on the phone and
just say you know piss off right
but then we'll just kind of hang around
we'll stick around and like six months
later
we'll be like hey what do you think
about our offer still
and they will sometimes still tell us to
piss off
up until like amy can go for like
sometimes like 12 months like up to like
what's some some of the longest ones
like
the third year there are so many of
these industrial single tenant
properties
i mean if you take your car and you
drive around
chicago every single corner is going to
have one
every corner yeah so every week we're
setting up meetings to go see
i mean he's not doing this so much but
i'm setting up meetings to go see these
properties
and after a day i'll get a list of the
equipment
and then i'll submit an offer and
whatever the asking price is
i do fifty percent so if it's if they're
asking 500 000
they just gotta double their price they
gotta double their price then all of a
sudden you'll offer
them asking instead of 500 okay i want a
mill all right
so i mean it's a waiting game what ends
up happening is like
because yani's going out and making so
many like
not so many offers but just like making
a decent amount of these offers on a
basically um you know most real estate
or people will say like how do you ever
buy real estate then because no one will
actually accept that offer but like
once in a blue moon not even a blue moon
like just every once in a while like
12 months like you find like a really
motive that's the key that's the key is
you have to find a very
motivated uh seller right someone who is
like
in you know wants the cash right away um
like i don't know maybe like their
spouse who owned the the building like
died and like they don't know what to do
with it they don't even know how to
manage it they just they don't even
so they just want to get rid of it
liquidate it so you have to find a very
motivated seller
um and you know but and sometimes that
and that typically
happens after 12 months of them not
getting their asking price right
so and then sometimes they'll i mean
they'll accept it and so they'll
and you jump at it but what happens if
you put in enough of these offers like
your offer it's like the deals that
you're making
are on offers that you started sometimes
up to a year ago
so you you know it kind of takes some
time right
but eventually once you are doing it
long enough like
you just start getting you know the time
catches up right
yeah the risk here is that if you get a
tenant someone moves out
finding a replacement tenant for yeah
would be difficult yeah
isn't always actually a problem because
for a lot of these properties it's their
owner users
so you find the motivated sellers from
the sellers when they're retiring from
using
the shop so they they're they're looking
to get out of the business
and additionally they leave all the
equipment behind
yeah so it's not so hard like we've
gotten some prop
some of these properties where there's
no one
we need to find a tenant with all the
equipment's inside so
for two of them i just picked up the
phone and like we're aggressive we're
like we take an aggressive stance on
everything
we do so i'll just call around every
surrounding neighborhood every area and
i'll talk
and i'll ask to speak to the owner or
manager and i'll say
hey we have another turnkey operation
business we're just investors looking
for a tenant
um all the equipment's inside we need a
uh security deposit and
first month's rent and you can get going
right away
good business yeah is it a good business
keep doing that what do you what do you
let's see jack you better see something
nothing that's just that's enough it's
30
that's just jack that's what you should
be doing do that what
you're going to encourage me to do that
listen 30
that's shocking 30 yeah that's time away
from work graham
that's shawn not if it's triple net
that's true
true um so i heard we were kind of
chatting before
filming this podcast because he wasn't
wearing socks
okay and it's kind of an issue because
if our guest isn't wearing socks or if
one of us isn't wearing socks including
socks yeah but your socks last episode
they had a they had a hole in them
a big hole we got some comments and your
feet were poking through
yeah we got comments about your feet uh
so i
i like how brooks starts recording as
soon as we're talking about my feet
i let you borrow my socks so you could
cover up your feet right
and uh you know i said we get a lot of
comments about the feet on this podcast
so everyone usually wears socks
and then you said that you you've sold
i mean if you're getting you guys were
speaking about
people messaging you to buy your the
pictures of your feet i didn't say no no
no george was saying
this is what happened so i sat down on
this couch right and i didn't come here
with socks on because
i'm enjoying the heat in vegas i'm from
chicago
so um then as soon as i asked well are
my feet gonna be in the shot and they
said yeah and i said
oh no no way am i doing this podcast
with no socks on at least not for free
right no at least not for free pay me
and how much did you want you said
jack you have to pay me if you want to
see my feet yeah
jack just said how much yeah you'd have
to pay me a lot
actually i feel like you could easily
get janna to do that for
look man i'll use it as my down payment
john is an entrepreneur whatever it
takes
is the price opportunist wait so so
people have actually asked
they've asked for feed pictures from you
for money haven't they asked you guys
no i wanted to buy my shoes and i
seriously i think
i think i'm gonna be doing it but the
only the only thing is that
we got to get the offer higher because
he offered a price where it's like it's
the cost of the shoe
i'm not gonna send him shoes worth the
price wasn't like 400 bucks no
it was less it was under that we're not
gonna we're not gonna get the exact
price because we don't want to lowball
ourselves
here right but it was a price it was
like that's the cost of the shoe at a
certain price
on a pair of shoes i don't like uh maybe
haven't worn a little bit i'm gonna
i'll send them off there's a price for
everything so yeah so what
what was your experience by the way i'm
trying to sell my bath water
it's on grahamstefstore.com five
thousand dollars
no one has got it yet it's a gallon too
it's not just a cup it's one gallon
think of shipping on that i have an idea
how much are you asking i could flip it
five thousand dollars
why don't we why don't we use that for
an aquarium
what great water in an aquarium yeah
would it be safe for a human just to dip
in
an aquarium oh that's what you're
wearing you don't want to wear like
sunscreens and stuff like that oh
it's inside why would you wear sunscreen
if it's inside if you if you're outside
with some
chemicals yeah chemicals in the aquarium
but i mean i just i don't know i thought
it was just common
it was funny because when we got you
know i i thought it was common like
everyone every influencer gets like
asked for fifa
so you you've gotten asked did you sell
your feed pictures or
um i did not i did not although it is
very very tempting sometimes
because it was the highest offer you
guys i feel like it wouldn't uh
highest offer was like two i don't know
like
a few hundred bucks wow dude come on
it's like what is it that's the thing if
you're just saying this isn't in it
though what if it's just like that's
what i'm saying is like yeah
it's it's so to me at least it's
innocent like
hey how are people gonna know they're my
feet and then b
like whatever if people like are in
defeat like i don't care you can be into
whatever you want
like 300 bucks for like some photos that
really do
take you a minute to take me like even
less than a minute they take me 10
seconds
and i mean he probably went up a little
bit it's tempting but i
i knew immediately what you were
referring to when you're like oh no
george like
you better get some socks yeah i was
like you bring me some socks i don't
want defeat people
defeat people i don't want i don't want
them i want them to
they better i don't know i'd rather than
focus on the conversation sure you know
i'm sure my feet are saying you're about
to get a little yeah man that's a
request
that's a strong community listen yeah
this for the fee people out there
we should be getting a percentage of
this because this right now is free
promotion
so if you sell if you sell any feed
pictures from this
we'll link it down below we want 20
percent yeah
10 of 10 10 gross that's too much
driving traffic you could set up an
instagram you know for georgia's feet
[Music]
we just want 10 whatever whatever
business you decide to do dude
i'm we're getting 30 percent gram i
don't i mean
we're getting 30 percent we don't want
we're giving you the traffic
we'll take 30 percent no no wait wait
wait we're getting 30 on real estate we
don't want oh
yeah we get 90
honestly to take a picture of your feet
uh
jack will do it for free graham would
you saw photos of your feet what is it
for the right price or what what is that
price
oh jeez uh i mean honestly a thousand
dollars it's like
a thousand dollars yeah that's a lot of
money
a thousand dollars dude literally
someone says jack i want to see my feet
dude i see your feet all the time bro i
see them all the time you must have
someone
else you don't have a picture they're
all right i don't have a picture where
you could look at it
dude i could get one when you're not
looking it would be so easy
dude i would sell a picture of my foot
for 20 bucks like literally it takes me
10 seconds why does it matter it's not
for me
a thousand dollars is the price where if
it ever got out that i had sold pictures
of my feet
no one could ever look at that and be
like i wouldn't have done i would
people would pat me on that they would
applaud everyone
gmail.com a thousand dollars and it will
send inquiries
even if it's you know someone that's
just associated with us andre
if you want to get pictures of feet of
andre let us know in your price to prove
it's my feet
is they could have me write something on
my foot that only they would know so
so it's like a time stamp like initial
blank i have no your
if i sell 10 pictures of my feet i'll
reinvest that money back into
creating some sort of nft one of them
for your feet
one of one of my left foot i want to
save
the right one in case i need it but one
better one do you have a better foot
what do you have a better foot no
they're the same thing but it's like
i'll keep one foot to myself what kind
of toes you have
you know how people people have like
different types of toes like oh yeah the
middle one will be out
yeah yeah yeah you don't want to spoil
the secret man no actually let's not
spoil the secret
yeah i was gonna say something that
would reveal the type of foot i have but
i just didn't want to spoil the secret
did you actually create the email yeah
grahamstuffandfeet gmail.com
we created the email we we actually did
create the email i'd be surprised
but i just just making it clear money
has to be paid up front don't worry i
mean it's not like
we're not gonna we're not gonna you know
go back
but but it'll have to be sent up front
before i said anything so i think that's
fair yeah or me
or alex yeah jack is only 20 bucks so
well
we'll see we'll get jack that's enough
to go get a nice meal
and if i can pay for a meal in 15
seconds in the box
[Music]
all right all right so what that said
you guys thank you so much for watching
i really appreciate it we'll link
to all of your information down below in
the description where you can also get
feed pictures make sure to also destroy
the like button
subscribe button and notification bell
and also you can get a free stock worth
all the way up to 70
dollars when you sign up for public
using link in the description
code gram 70 and you'll have a chance to
win a completely free stock of tesla so
you may as well do that it's pretty much
like free money
thank you guys so much for coming on
thanks you guys so much for watching and
until next time
see now you're loose enough now you're
going to kill it
all right